ihr vater ist fingern ihre mutter ist in
und estlands komplexe geschichte ihr
thema sofi oksanen auf den spuren ihrer
romanfiguren in tallinn für
schriftsteller sind orte wie der
freiheitsplatz auf dem wir stehen
fantastisch man sieht die stadt sowie
die romanfiguren sie gesehen haben
können hat dieses café zum beispiel
heißt jetzt vaduz freiheit vor dem krieg
hieß es café tass das heißt gold war
sehr kosmopolitisch und berühmt wegen
seiner kuchen und jetzt gehen
rosi kann die straße
buchs about the patients in island gibt
es geschichten über deportationen es
gibt erinnerungen und biografie in jener
menschen die in den westen viel mussten
und geschichten über jene die hier
bleiben muss doch es gibt keine
geschichten über kollaborateure ich aber
denke es ist wichtig kollaborateuren
gesicht zu geben und zu verstehen wie
sie arbeiten und was für leute das waren
kollaborateure gab es zwangsläufig wenn
estland wurde mehrmals besetzt
zuerst von den sowjets dann von den
deutschen und schließlich wieder von den
sowjets opfern ins roman beginnt 1941
mit dem einmarsch der wehrmacht
sie schildert das leben zweier männer
die auf demselben hof aufwachsen und
sich dem antideutschen widerstand
anschließen
doch dann verlieren sie sich der eine
geht in den untergrund der andere macht
karriere unter den besatzern und zwar
sowohl unter den deutschen als auch
später unter den sowjets als ich zu
schreiben begann realisierte ich dass
leute meines alters dachten die
sowjetunion so etwas verstaubtes an dass
man keinen gedanken verschwenden sollte
aber ich denke wenn man in finnland lebt
dann muss man einfach etwas über ausland
und in estland erst recht 1944 lösen die
einen besitzer die anderen ab estland
wird der sowjetunion einverleibt eine
neue ära des misstrauens beginnt wieder
werden menschen verhaftet und deportiert
der besuch in einer ehemaligen abhör
station des kgb lässt erinnerungen wach
werden
auch bei sofi oksanen die als kind mit
ihren eltern oft aus finnland anreiste
es war uns nicht erlaubt meine
großeltern zu besuchen
die mieten auf dem land und man wollte
den besuchern aus dem westen keine
kolchose bauern zeit
der zweite teil von opfern ins buch
spielt zur zeit der sowjetischen
besatzung in den 60er jahren
hauptfigur edgar betätigt sich
inzwischen als propaganda schriftsteller
für den kgb mit hilfe eines wörterbuches
verbiegt er historische fakten genosse
parts überlebte das lager in dem er sich
tot stellte dank seiner klugheit tritt
er heute als zeuge gegen die
faschistischen parasiten auf und
berichtet die wahrheit zu meiner großen
überraschung musste ich feststellen dass
viele jener männer die zur zeit der
sowjetischen besatzung estlands
geschichtsbücher nach den anweisungen
des kgb schrieben im zweiten weltkrieg
schon für den deutschen
sicherheitsdienst tätig gewesen war
es sieht also fast so aus als ob
diktaturen eine ganz bestimmte art von
menschen bevorzugen hauptfigur
enttäuscht alle zuerst die deutschen
dann die sowjets sogar seine eigene
familie und das in einer gesellschaft in
der jeder den anderen kennt oder zu
kennen glaubt leute haben immer
geheimnisse voreinander
es gibt so viele ehen in denen der mann
seine eigene frau nicht kennt oder die
frau ihren mann nicht
ich denke es geht um die fundamentale
frage unserer existenz ist es wirklich
möglich einen anderen menschen zu kennen